[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is a hilarious
youtuber and comedian Lee Newton of
course you know Lee as one of the
co-hosts of the popular news and current
events show on YouTube SourceFed Farley
Lucille Ball and Frank Ralph Waldo
Emerson the cast of heroes of course but
a robber from Jacksonville Florida might
have to be added to my list why a robber
or hero robbed Jerome barbecue last week
and so $4,000 worth of chicken wings and
fries from the restaurant not sure I
know what you're thinking wait I hear us
a thief why are you guys praising him
but this is Farscape up jerks also how
did he do it and why now we always known
Lee is extremely funny intelligent we've
enjoyed collaborating with her she was a
guest on the mythical show but we didn't
really know her too well personally and
we definitely didn't know the backstory
of the health problems that she has
dealt with since she was a child
yeah I really appreciated her candor and
we got to a lot of good things in
addition to that we talked about
homemade jams yeah her landing a spot on
the Maxim top 100 and I really enjoyed
getting her perspective very thoughtful
on women in comedy yeah and we also
heard her story about her embarrassing
herself in target oh yeah we'd like to
thank our sponsor sharise berries for
giving me a reason to eat berries again
namely because they're coated in
chocolate white milk or dark also topped
with chocolate chips decorative swizzle
swizzle or nine a house basically the
perfect delivery mechanism for all those
things is a berry and we we got some of
these for the crew here and I will say
that they broke them out and ate all of
them before they told us that they had
them you didn't get one I didn't get any
I'm okay you got some yeah how many did
you get
three I mean what's three there they're
huge berries I suppose but I mean I
could have probably eaten
did you not think that you needed to ask
me you know I assumed you know who I
can't keep track of everybody's bear I'm
getting a batch for myself if you're one
of the ninety nine point three percent
of people who have yet to figure out
where they're gonna get their sweetheart
for Valentine's Day we can make it easy
for you go to berries calmness BERR IES
calm click on the microphone and type in
our code rhett and Link so the note will
sense you and if you use that code you
get a chance to double the berries for
$10 more I love the fact that they on
the website berries dot-com I mean
that's legitimizing to me why don't they
bought that from someone or if they were
just like sitting on it a long time it I
mean I don't care what the more
important message to me is that they own
berries calm and they're doing something
with their berries are covered in
chocolate and goodness as a berry should
be right is the person who owns
cantaloupe calm are they doing something
useful with it I don't know I don't go
there are they coating their cantaloupes
in chocolate and swizzle and nuts
probably not assortment start at $19.99
and you can get over a 40% savings off
regular price thanks Sherri's berries
okay let's get into this ear biscuit
with Lee Newton I believe you will enjoy
it as much as we did
okay Lee I've been stalking you on
Twitter on December 1 December 30th you
tweeted just bought a Taylor Swift album
at a Walmart I am America I am America
so I'm assuming that you were not around
here if you were at a Walmart because
nobody goes no I was actually up north
where home is and I was on my way to
home and there was a Walmart cuz again
there are no Walmart's in LA yeah and I
was there and I bought them because also
I was like $8.99 did you were you
looking for
no Walmart so that you could buy a
Taylor Swift if you want to no I was
looking for a Walmart so I could
purchase jars because I make jam for
Christmas every year and Walmart has the
best choices for jam everyone knows that
like mason jars like mason jars for jam
you make jam I make jam I do so you go
home to where I go home to Yosemite well
a little town right outside you somebody
actually but I say Oh somebody cuz no
one knows where what's cold is course
gold horse of course go horse what it's
like its cargo like a mining town it's a
mining town it is it still actually has
like weird little mining things you can
always find and you can find the mining
holes and you go there and it's magical
but there's not a Walmart in course gold
blood no no there's a Walmart like in
Fresno which is about an hour away from
enroute so you stop there i'ma get my
mason jars on the way and then you make
the jam once you get back into homestead
yes I mean I make a lot of it at my home
in LA but still there's stuff you know
like I go up north before Christmas
because I still very much love and adore
my parents some people don't feel that
way about your parents no no I actually
I think most people love and adore them
they're kind of those there's those
people that you just they're just the
most alike for humans in the world and
you just love them and I want to be
around them all the time and I really
you know jam with him I do I do I would
never live with them because I think I
would drive them insane
but also and they would too because they
love elementary on CBS and I can't get
into it is the jam making a family
affair or
I'm gonna make Jam alone in my father
there's a most impossible person to buy
presents for ever because it wouldn't
he's one of those that like if you want
something he gets it and that's what it
is any research is it well he deserves
it he deserves it he works hard he's a
great guy everybody likes so I last year
like three years ago I was like I'm
gonna make jam for him I'm just gonna
cuz he likes sweet things ever made Jane
no never had you made stuff like foods I
make food you know it's a natural
propensity towards women that we bake
you know but yeah I'd made stuff and
then I just decided to make him Jam and
then it like I turned out to be OK at it
and the kind of thing what kind of jam
oh well auntie Lee's Jam the one that is
really big is razzmatazz it's like a
lemon raspberry so yeah you branded it
yes I have 100% branded a now and now
like the brother-in-law is like it's
that good it's it's a thing it's a thing
now so all types you get types I got
razzmatazz blackberry Fields it's a real
another really big one Strawberry Fields
but that's like with a little bit of
Apple like there's a lot of different
things last year I tried a Christmas one
it was like cranberry and apple and so
you're gonna are you thinking about like
fall back I'm thinking Shark Tank but
maybe that's just me I'm here at
Christmas jam but I just don't see it
taking up much further than my father
and brother in law's palette and
actually everyone in my family cuz we're
big do you have stickers auntie leaves
stickers but you print on an inkjet
aunty Lee made this it's good to be to
be able to give a gift that is something
that you've created yes especially if
the people like it yes it's like a big
deal yeah that's like the that's like
the perfect alignment for a great gift
my dad makes his own barbecue sauce I
don't know if I told you this oh you've
had it but it's I've had it
it's a tomato chicken yeah it's a
chicken barbecue sauce and more than a
born at a pork but you can put it on
anything it's it's a vinegary but still
tomato we based things which is is a
very North Carolina yeah oh yeah no need
to go into detail except that at
Christmastime we all meet at his mom's
house in Nana and Papa's house have more
people than ever this past Christmas and
everyone's opening their gifts and then
we finally get to a point where dad
leaves the room then he comes back and
he's got these big jugs he's handing out
jugs and it's just like Costco size so
on the jug
it's just Costco no like a to and from
size it no no you don't I guess once you
taste it you're happy I guess but there
we used ketchup and but I don't get one
because of the cross country track yeah
you don't want that vinegar so it's gold
used to order barbecue sauce from a man
in Mississippi that made it out of his
basement and it was like and he recently
the old guy passed away apparently and
when I was like hoarding it but that
stuff is worth its weight in gold and
he'd better ship it to you if it's good
I mean if you can put it on it I'm a big
barbecue sauce on everything I really
like your dad maybe work out a trade
yeah I think that's like what you jam
for sauce yeah I'm just saying you know
I'm a man who has that kind of
discretion about barbecue sauce and he
does you know my rub like Oh what does
your dad do he's a pastor really what
what of what variety it's actually a
non-denominational Church and it's up
again in the mountain area does he have
a beard no he has a mustache yes only oh
no no I think I remember you showing us
a picture of your dad's mustache one two
maybe I'm that's coming back to me maybe
when we shot for the mythical show it's
something else is your home screen on
your phone yes I probably might have
been my home screen I'm like my
beautiful parents so what I mean is this
like a small Valley Church or a actually
a pretty big church especially for the
area it's actually a very big church and
they kind of they're nondenominational
and they're very open loving and they
kind of specialize and people that
recover our recovery like so you know
addicts and all that they have a lot of
programs for those like wonderful people
and it's kind of they have big hearts in
that sense and so it was this what he's
done your entire life mm-hmm so you grew
up as a yes i PK there's a PK a pastor's
kid and I think I was a big reason why
he went back into the ministry because
really before me he was doing just fine
in real estate actually Morpha and then
I think he ever did in ministry as far
as like money-wise but yeah it was a big
reason why he went back into the
ministry because I came along and I had
a horrific heart problem and it kind of
Oh me come along man born born okay yeah
born so he went into the ministry he
wanted to be a minister and then and
then he got caught up in life and then
he was really good at real estate and he
was really good at business and he was
making a lot of money they lived in
Oregon and you know him and my mom both
you know
oh he retired at mid-30s and and had a
whole bunch of you know we had a goats
and kind of like a big thing out and a
big ranch out in Oregon and then and
then I came along and company went under
and I had a horrible heart problem and
and so it was kind of a big reassess
moment for him I think
okay so excited horrible heart moment
little heart let's get into this problem
it's my new let's unpack it I mean and
and I mean it must this must be big
sounds big when was this discovered this
was discovered I was born to a midwife
like I was born in a with him and wife
because my mom had had both of her other
kids older brother and sister in a
hospital so you know low low chances of
anything bad happening and it was also
the 80s so they didn't know better but
they had me at to a midwife and then I
am and then I 14 days into it I think my
father was like something's wrong like
the kids blue and not responding I'm
just finding in the way that she should
and my mother was like she's perfect
leave her alone she's my baby because
mothers do that there's
hormones and and then it was one of
those things where he was like no we're
going to the hospital so took me to the
hospital at 14 days I had my first
open-heart surgery because basically
what it is in a long-term is my heart is
backwards two out of the four chambers
are missing a meaning Artic are Chris
fused a lot of like a like valves and
yada yada yada so you seem to have just
lift lists at least four four major
problems major things yes yeah missing
chambers missing backwards backwards
those are two big ones right yeah
ventral septal defect atrial septal
defect pulmonary stenosis transposition
of the great vessels is what the
technical terms of it all are but it
basically means that you know missing
valves meeting valves need to be
replaced
missing chambers yadda yadda but the
cool thing is if all of that hadn't been
if I had just had one diagnosis I would
have been dead if I had just had two of
the diagnoses I would have been dead but
because I had multiple ones of them they
all kind of worked out all the problems
work together together to make me alive
14 days
Wow yeah so I mean you know it's kind of
magical beautiful thing and so what did
they do when they no they went in when I
was a baby they went in through my back
because I was little and they can't go
in through your front and so they
basically you know patched up the are
who the holes in my heart and then they
reworked everything to where it's still
backwards it'll always be backwards it's
just what it is they can't flip it
because that's apparently really
dangerous
um that's already connected to
everything so rewired everything did a
valve and then throughout my whole life
I've had at two years I had another one
it was more like 14 months they had
another one and then at seven I had a
really big one which is replacing this
valve and making sure everything is
actually succinct and okay because it
was a heart growing and they needed to
fix it mm-hmm and then at 13 I had
another one and there's you know I mean
there's a lot of different multiple
things that go along with it so you I
mean so you remember the seven year old
I remember the seven year old one
viciously yeah I mean I like 13 months
old you wouldn't know no I know I don't
remember that I remember being a sick
kid that's all I remember
and I
only what yes sir what were the symptoms
as a you know four four five six year
old I would always be blue so I always
had exigent deprivation so I was always
had blue lips blue face it was called
they're called blue babies actually with
people with heart problems and so I
would always have blue lips and people I
was also very little I was so little I
was forty-five pounds at like five years
old which is so small and people just
thought it was ingenious little blue
really smart guy was always that and I
remember people would always pick me up
that was the biggest thing that I
remember is I don't think I walked
anywhere for like ever because people
just felt bad you need to be carried
random strangers my brother would always
have me on his back he was always giving
me back rides because he just couldn't
fathom the blue child walking and so
that was the biggest thing I remember
about being sick also about having a
make-a-wish and then turning to my
mother and asking if I was gonna die oh
my I mean I remember a lot of stuff so
this was a touch-and-go yeah we'll get
into how to go at this point but what
was your make-a-wish Disneyland I was
five I had siblings Disneyland but does
I mean does make a wish does that mean
that like okay we don't know this we
don't know it was before the seven year
old it was kind of one of those we don't
know it was uh it was very much a we
don't know we don't know whether or not
you know I mean there's thirty I
remember it dawning on you yeah Disney
World
Disneyland because I was treating me so
wonderfully and I knew I was a sick kid
so it was like one of those like I
remember turning and I had a Donald like
in my hand I turned I was like I'm gonna
die and I was like and and I just
remember the whole trip like literally
we had to be having so much fun of my
siblings to be like we're gonna miss you
so dark and so everything in hindsight
it's one of the funniest moments of my
life because it's it's fantastic
what's your relationship with Disney at
this point at Disney at this point it
was just heavy it was also like let's go
on the teacups or like kimchi comedy
what about now okay
can you watch it yeah I can without the
plot holes but I can come on Olaf gives
the true love you know you know it's for
her clearly
yeah figured out but yeah I mean I can
do Ivan actually recently was talking
about going to Disneyland again cuz when
I went when I was younger it was like a
kind of dark it was like one of those
like I think I like this I have bad
memories magical wonderful days but now
it's different I think because another
surgery at 13 mm-hmm and was that the
final one no I'll have to have open
heart surgeries my whole life it's a car
it's like a you know like you go and
replace the things that are in there and
so I mean there's valves the good thing
is is my one I was 13 was supposed to
last like maybe six to eight years and
now it has last six 16 so it's kind of
like you know that in it of itself is a
miracle is this like a pig valve
situation it is it's a bovine valve
actually oh you got bovine bovine valve
I got bovine valve I got cortex I got
wire in the chest I got 37 year old male
artery I got all of it I got all really
tough yeah so you got a little peep a
little another person in there you got
an animal a million people's blood in
there so so what okay so what is the the
day-to-day with this condition is this
the kind of thing that's like I can't
get too excited because I might have a
heart attack you know I can't do this no
I think and I think so much of it is
mind over matter it really is because
I've been to sick groups with with
people with my condition and I'm like oh
god I am NOT these people like I am so
far beyond that and a lot of that was
good parenting honestly was my parents
going like I'm like I'm gonna run to the
river and they're like great as they're
panicking behind to see if I'm okay but
never once did they ever say I couldn't
do anything like honestly ever it was
one of those things I remember there was
one field trip I couldn't go on because
the elevation was too high and they were
like we just can't like you're a
liability we can't do it I'm like my
school wouldn't let me and my parents
like we'll take her we'll make sure
she's okay but I mean I should never
have gone up that high in elevation and
even now you can't fly no I can
absolutely fight but it's just like
walking like so I could never do Everest
I know that now I'm just gonna get two
ways it's gonna
oxygen most people can't do Everest like
most people you know like if you have
any I cannot you cannot yeah I'm just
gonna go on I tried tried it got the
base camp and turn back I mean there's a
dead zone if something's called a dead
zone I don't aspire to go there yeah
exactly so no I mean there's things in
that sense but a lot of it is just me
going no I can do this I know I can like
and pushing yourself and knowing that
you're gonna be okay and I have faith
that I'm gonna be okay and and I am a
really good governor of myself like I've
never you know again marathon not gonna
happen for me I think I could absolutely
if I tried and if I train and if I
really felt comfortable with it but how
do you know when it's time for another
surgery
hey what are the signs that's the
dilemma is that I go every six months I
get checked out and I'll just say you
know there's like valves that are like
thickening and closing and so they have
to worry about that and then there's
like things like that shunts that are
leaking and they have to you know kind
of do they do a million-and-a-half tests
on you to see you know if this is okay
if that's okay and then they just kind
of deduct from there the cool thing
about it is that I have a like a killer
surgeon a killer killer surgeon he's
like you know top three in the world and
so interesting choice of words there
yeah sure what he well I just remember
like vividly when I was seven he looked
like he I think he came off like a ski
trip when I when I was like rushing like
I don't goggles yeah like he was just
like oh you know he's this Australian
guy that just like came off the ski trip
and I was like how does this male model
nice he's a big deal yeah
so you seemed to describe the you being
born and that happening as a real
turning point in your dad's life I think
families life in him beginning to be a
pasture again
I'm curious what what what's been your
source of strength in coping mechanism
I mean there was no turning point that
was the beginning of your life but I'm
curious if it sounds like that you have
a real gift for a sis of humor associate
I mean obviously in general but
associated
this did you always deal with it with a
sense of humor what is that something
you developed later as a seven as a 13
year old were you able to laugh at this
even now I would imagine it's difficult
no it's not honestly it's not it's kind
of like the hand that you're dealt you
kind of just I mean that you know it's
odd there are so many worse things that
I could have that could have happened in
my life but I do I think I I made the
decision I actually remember making the
decision to to laugh it off to like be
it was our in the hospital and my mother
was actually there and she says now like
she remembers the moment that it
happened there was this girl likes me
and she was whining to the nurses she
was just whining and complaining the
whole time
and I made I made a joke like I was
joking around with the nurses and they
loved me and they was more attention it
was more like it was a happier
environment because I was joking around
about stuff and I remember deciding from
that moment that I was like oh this
can't be something serious in my life
like this can't be the end-all be-all
like it can't be something that takes
everything over because I define you I
can't define you it really can't can
define you in a way that you that it
propels you but I can't like do anything
else than that and I remember making a
cognitive choice of just being like this
is so much easier it's so much easier to
laugh about this it's so much easier to
just joke about all this and find a
sense of humor in it it sounds like you
always had this instinct for humor as
well that you were all were you always
the funny girl I was a big part of it
was called I was like the funny girl and
it was always the chunky girl too so
that was like that was hand in hand like
okay hand but yeah I was always the
weird I mean like class clown in high
school like just the weird kid because
it's so much easier and when did you
start funneling that into entertaining
people um
I mean honestly as soon as I could as
soon as I could I started and it was I
mean I knew I wanted to be an actor
pretty much like at a child level child
age I was like I want to do this I want
him however this can happen however
laughter can happen and I can get paid
for it I want to do that so then I you
know I did stand-up for a couple of
years and I really liked it but I didn't
like the scene of it and I it was
basically in like in like Yosemite
Valley has so many valley
no I decided I I was gonna move out to
LA my brother had moved to LA and he was
he's an entertainer as well and he'd
moved to LA musician's musician and he's
a he's a really good actor too but he is
an incredible musician and he has taken
that road and that road has taken him
and so it's yeah he moved out here and I
was like well he's out there and I can
go out there with him and then and then
I moved out to LA and what stage are we
talking high schooler out of high school
right out of high school I was like I
know I want to go out there and try it
and do it and then I went to Community
College and Pasadena crazy theater
directors that led me in really great
ways because they were actually working
actors which is a fascinating thing to
me that I had a teacher that was a real
working actor and being like instead of
like so I watch you on General Hospital
you come in here and yeah I see I've
seen you in Top Gun and now you're gonna
walk done oh yeah he was like one person
a Top Gun but he said that paid for
multiple homes well yeah so it was like
this crazy old man that reminded me of
the dude from Big Lebowski that was a
big hand and what actually made me go
out and do stand-up and do that cuz he
was just like you would oh he would
always be like you know you're funny
that's not a thing that happens with
women go do it and you just be like
alright as misogynistic as it was he was
not wrong why why did you why is that I
don't know I mean you know it's actually
a difficult world I think for women it's
just one of those things where there's
multiple facets coming at you of it
there's you I've been in the writing
room with men where you say one idea no
one listens to you someone says the
exact same idea and they're like good
job bro and you're like whew like uh-huh
eat it you know so I've been in those
rooms too and I've also been in the
weird thing where there's constantly if
we're gonna get really podium about it
there's an intense sexual ization of
women and so immediately I'm not funny
if I'm pretty I'm not funny if I am
remotely attractive or if I am what's
wrong with me like where did it come
I remember sitting in a group of girls
like actual comedian girls that I
surround myself with out of my friends
and we went around the circle when we
like what's wrong with you and it
literally was a list of like well I used
to be a fat girl like I had issues with
my father like this it was like these
things that we were all laughing about
but it was also a weird thing of like
because we had to like push through and
find this personality and it's not
saying that these like amazing model
type people can't be funny it's just
there's it it doesn't happen not often
because they're sexualized immediately
and they don't need to and you know it's
it's just a weird thing that I find that
it's actually very very difficult
because you know even Tina Fey it's like
well let's see her be sexy and you're
like does she does she have to be right
do we have to boil it down like Amy
Poehler oh she's hideous no make up and
you're like yeah who everyone is
autotrophs without makeup like we all
look different so it's just that weird
thing that I think from day one people
tiptoe around it it's getting better I
do think it's getting better it's
getting more of an industry I think it's
fascinating when people are like wow
women are really coming out in comedy
hon you're like actually Lucille Ball
changed the entire freakin television at
the point but but sure yeah women are
come Alisa McCarthy's amazing you know
like it's a weird thing where you go
like this woman single-handedly changed
the way we film television but you know
are you saying that a lot of the most
successful female comedians are have
been damaged in some way or theirs but
they've had to overcome something I
don't think so I think they've had to
make a choice I do think that they have
had to make a choice of that road to go
down I think it's a weird thing like you
have the option now where it's like in
order to choose comedy it's kind of a
hard road like it's kind of one of those
things of like no I want to do this
because I love it because it's funny and
like sure like Amy Schumer is beautiful
she's a beautiful girl but she'd made
the choice to be like I'm gonna be this
brash out-there person I think it is a
choice I think it's one of those things
that it's not because it's like well you
know they're funny so just like let them
go it's like it for a woman it tends to
be a choice it tends to be a choice of
not being funny but like really deciding
like no I'm gonna be a comedy girl I'm
going to be this is what I'm gonna be
and it's okay that everyone's gonna try
and sexualize me are they're gonna try
and not give me a
because I'm too unattractive or I'm too
this or to that well it seems like you
know you were dealing with this in the
comedy world yes
and III want to connect the dots but I
can't resist the fast-forward - well
then you enter the internet world where
it's a it's the same story maybe even
Morris because there's comments ya know
I mean it's the same and I think it'll
always be the same world I think it
really will I think the Internet is more
heightened versions of it because people
can get behind a keyboard and type
things out and and I've noticed that a
lot and it gets the good thing about the
internet is because is that there's a
community of everyone so there are
beautiful young women that you see that
see you being new and it's really cool
and they go oh this person has a
personality and maybe I can too and you
know like or this person isn't you know
fixated on this or that different thing
about themselves I think you don't have
to check as many boxes of a gatekeeper
yes to be your true self and to find ya
and every other people who are true
being true to themselves as an audience
and it's nice it's also I mean I don't
know I would have loved like when I'm
growing up like I'd the people that I
latched on to it was always the weirdos
there's always these weird wonderful
women that like you know those were who
I latched on to because I was like
that's me are you thinking about someone
in particular uh well I was a big gilda
radner fan I was a huge Gilda Radner fan
and she was just she was weird and she
was adorable like yes I know I said no
like I said no and also just like in
general like any any interview I've seen
them all like I loved her but she was
such a weirdo and I would just I
remember just being like I'm okay like I
am okay being a weirdo it's not like
anything else like you can be goofy and
weird and that's totally okay and that
was like one of those things I'm Amy
Poehler is a big one - Sheri Oteri like
obviously on SNL - but there are those
big people that you grew up with that
you're like oh that's totally okay like
it gives you that release of like when
you're a young girl growing up being
like oh there's plenty there's dozens of
us so you get to LA you're you're doing
the the community college thing yes and
you are trying to find roles going to
auditions like what was the worldís
story was i I was
goofy I did a whole bunch of theater and
you know at the Community College and
then I had a teacher that was like that
that big lebowski dude he was like I
need to do stand-up he was like I need
you to write me like a seven minute set
of stand-up and I was like he's like do
it and so I did that and then he
actually was the one that booked me like
a million my teacher booked me a million
different gigs really yeah doing
stand-up he's a magic like it was one of
those big people in my life like that
was my Good Will Hunting everybody go
that's a good teacher that's a teacher
take me to the first stand-up because
that sounds terrifying it was terrifying
it was terrifying it was in the stupid
little coffee shop in Pasadena and
remember doing it and being like I don't
hate this like I don't I did it and I
was just like and then I remember a big
part of it was actually like being able
to like mess with the crowd and talk
with the crowd interact with the crowd
and I was like I really don't hate this
on any level and then I decided to keep
doing it and then did you know different
things I went to the ice house I did all
these different little things I didn't
take it as far as Hollywood I did like
college stuff and then I went I decided
to keep going and then it was just a
really acerbic kind of thing that I was
just like in this comedy world of really
angry people that are very upset that
they didn't get it do a set on you know
Leno and was that you mean the people
that you had to people that I hang out
had to hang out with and I I mean like
it it's a it's a tough world for anyone
because again that's just you which is
you putting forward your stuff you
hoping that people pick it up it depends
it's such a weird thing because there's
rooms are different every night people
are different there a night it's and
especially for comedy like I don't make
people laugh do that is that when you
switched to more of an improv Lane yeah
it was more I and then I'd always heard
I grew up learning The Groundlings and
knowing about Groundlings and everyone
that I'd loved had been a part of the
growling so Cheri Oteri Melissa McCarthy
and you know like all these wonderful
amazing Kristen Wiig these wonderful
amazing women had been a part of it and
so
I was like I have to give this a whirl
so I auditioned for it and then got into
classes and it's a huge long process
yeah there's a whole there's a whole
system right where a whole system it's
all hierarchy it's all crazy and again
it's all comedy so it shouldn't be that
you start I mean you start I've never
done it and I've just kind of heard that
there's you take classes then you move
to a team where you're performing but
then there's the hierarchy that you're
talking about as different teams that
perform and on different nights or
different times there's more high
profile that's it's a that's more the
UCB that Groundlings is like a class you
wait and then you take another class and
if you pass that class you get to go
into this Writing Lab and if you pass a
writing lab if you don't pass a writing
line be done with the program like cut
from the whole program completely and
then if you do writing lab so it's all
it's a sudden death process every every
point even when you get into the
pinnacle of the school which is Sunday
company which is every single week you
are writing Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
Wednesday you pitch Thursday you decide
what goes in the show Friday you're
getting costume Saturday rehearse Sunday
it's up it's live it's a brand-new show
every single week and I did that for a
year and a half in this last year and it
was so year and a half of my life where
I probably pitched over 2,000 sketches
Wow
over and over again probably performed
about I know I performed about two
hundred and thirty or two and thirty two
is my final number of like how many
sketches I performed which is insane and
you just go and you do this brand new
show every single week and even in that
they vote on you every six months like
wasn't you saying and again at the end
of the day it's like it's comedy you
know like it's JJ Abrams didn't pass a
program so hmm you know cuz he's not a
good writer like I was like I'm in a
mistake so there's people along the way
that like don't even get into the
program that you're like sweet Dee from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia who I
think is phenomenal Kaitlin Olson she
made like one term and Sunday company
and I was like but you made it soon I'm
fresh you're fresh off of coming all the
way through the process two and a half
year process it was well in
I love my life it was a six year process
you know I should have a doctorate so
yeah what's supposed to be the the goal
is that you get into the main company
Groundlings the goal is that but there's
a lot of people that get cut along the
way I was like one of those people that
that happened to where it was just like
you know thank you so much for the year
and a half like we don't see a place for
you in the main company growling and
you're like okay great we move on how
does that I mean is that a dramatic
point in your life because what is it
what is that last moment is it cut does
it come down to one performance and then
get a report card no you would think it
would how does it work how did it work
for you specifically it worked for me
specifically I did a year and a half of
stuff I did a year and a half of you
know crazy madness I grew a lot
I had these phenomenal teachers that you
know really shaped me along the way one
of them was very akin to JK Simmons role
in whiplash she I mean she is a intense
like she's a comedy Nazi but she made
everyone magnificent and fantastic and
like it was a weird moment when I was
like when she was giving someone
attitude and she was like name a person
that you like that's from this school
I've taught them and I was like she's
not you know she gave that speech like
Will Ferrell taught him and you're like
that's very fair um you know so it's all
those people that you go well I can't
deny this woman's 28 years of comedy
knowledge right and you painted to go
through in hindsight whenever you're
explaining it to anyone else in the
world they're like why why would you do
this but at the end of the day you
perform every week on a stage that like
your favorite people have performed on
like I've touched the same areas that
Melissa McCarthy and Kristen Wiig and
like Jim rush and all these like Will
Ferrell take it back to like Jon Lovitz
Phil Hartman like all these people
there's some insane it's real amazing
that you just go I love this you're a
part of something that legacy something
a legacy but then it comes down to a
decision yeah it's not how does that
work it's I think it's I mean it's all
very illuminating but I mean are you
locked in a cell and they slide like
well it's basically they all go in a
room and they vote and see if that
person goes on to the main company if
they don't and
would that mean being part of the main
company we would mean how would that
change your life you know I think it
used to mean a lot more I think it would
normally change people's I was because
it was a bigger deal like it was one of
those things where it was like you know
you got on the wall and you know Lisa
Kudrow and and Kathy Griffin both you
know Groundlings alum and so they got on
the wall and then they're like oh well
the main company groundling great like
give her a role on this and fantastic
and then they move on but now it's just
a different world it's just a different
like people are they're a lot longer and
staying a lot and it's just a different
thing for me it was like a hard blow of
like you know I was disappointed I was
very disappointed I didn't make it
because it's you're always going up to
like an end goal of something but
immediately right afterwards I realized
the people in my company that had been
cut from the program as well we're like
these amazing people that I was like oh
I'd rather be in this like when I look
back at like who has been there along
the way but it okay but I there's that
moment I think it's it's a system that
most people can't relate to but I think
what we can all relate to is that moment
of decision where it's you were told was
it a person who told you yeah it was a
director that told me like the vote
didn't go your way and you go okay but
in all fairness I had been to Burning
Man had got my tarot cards read and they
said in my tarot cards that it wasn't
gonna go my way so that was your
response it was a guy in a bathrobe that
was reading right here like I couldn't
were in the middle of the desert in the
bathroom reading my tarot cards I can't
you know is eating a chewy granola bar
but busy so you see me prepared I said I
prepared for the moment because of the
Tower of Terror card that was but see
even I think that's the beauty of it
even right now you exhibit it is the the
humor as an ability to process
disappointment yeah I mean you're
telling us that every six months you're
having an experience like that where a
guy in a bathrobe or a medical gown or
whatever they doctors wear these days I
don't think they
or tarot card it come scrubs link and
you're having to give that response its
I mean I can make the argument that
you're you're conditioned on a heart
level
yes get a little cheesy here to to to to
to dominate in this atmosphere in this
in the world of entertainment because
it's everyone talks about it's a series
of rejections until you get what you
want yeah it really is
yeah it really is where you get a little
bit or do you even want life you get
what you want you know it really is like
it's not just this industry because it's
every it's every industry it's just or
is it even about getting what you want
or is it even more about not getting
what you want
no I can't help but think that the your
transition to the Internet and the
success of SourceFed also also makes
that a little easier to take because you
know you could that not that it's
necessarily safety net I don't want to
use the wrong analogy but it wasn't you
didn't have all your hopes tied up in
that right no I did this because you
were already doing something that my you
know it's like when you get to create
you know it's like you get to create
what you say that that's a really nice
thing being a key master it's a
beautiful thing being like I'm the
master of my domain like I know what the
voice is that I'm putting out into the
world they don't have to worry about
anyone else writing stuff for me I don't
have to worry about anything and that's
a beautiful thing so I think it did help
a lot in that sense where I just go well
you know like we shake it off and move
on and you know I'm still doing what I
love still doing what I want to do I
just quoted your Walmart CD I did also
Mariah Carey oh um you know did you how
did you see the SourceFed opportunity
when it came about and what how did that
happen honestly um it was it was such a
random thing it was I I didn't on it I
honestly had no I
I mean I knew about the internet because
I a weld a lot but uh but I didn't know
like it was just one of those things
that I had I had an agent at the time
that was like hey here's this thing but
the good news is you get to write your
own stuff and what do you think and I
went into some weird hole in the wall
audition place and I remember there was
they were also auditioning models that
day but not for source but for something
else and I just remember walking and
going like I don't think I'm in the
right place here and it was just we got
pop culture news things that we had to
give our own opinions on and I had no
idea who Philip DeFranco was it was
filling the room at this point no I was
just the producers and it was actually I
remember the person that put me it at
most huge was Danny Rosenberg like she's
amazing and she works for Phil and she's
at the offices all the time and she
laughed and remember being like oh thank
god like there's someone laughing here
because it was a hard room it was
actually a kind of a difficult room and
then you was like all these dudes and
Joe was one of those that was like you
know he comes off so intense at first
but I was just like you were auditioning
for Joe I was auditioning with Joe with
Joe with Joe and I auditioned with Steve
and I auditioned with Elliott as well so
they were already in they were already I
don't know if they know she was saying
they were they were all I remember Joe
came off really intense at first when I
was like nah man I make this kid my
friend and I like immediately just
started being very lovey to him and he
you know melted like a stick of butter
and it was just one of those very I
don't know it was just I remember
ranting about pop culture things and
them not thinking about it again until
they called like not even thinking it
was just one of those like well I'm in a
hole in the wall like once again a hole
in the wall where I get to do this I do
remember getting really excited about
having my own opinion about something
and being able to put that straight
forward and then it was I mean I guess
the rest is history
you got through the gauntlet and yeah
we're the main host but it was a crash
course in Internet and yeah and Internet
yeah yeah so what was that like what was
that process of okay I'm on this thing
if you hadn't been watching youtube
videos
yeah know anything about the world and
all of a sudden you're a face of a very
popular thing yeah I mean
I was honestly was one of those like I I
had no idea what I was getting into I
had no idea what I was getting into I
remember the first week Elliott Morgan
made me sign up for Twitter because I
was like what's Twitter and he was like
good god like so he made my Twitter name
he made my Twitter hit like handle he
set me up on Twitter and then you know I
mean it was actually very overwhelming
but I was just like I think were a part
of something I think we're a part of
something it was one of those like I
think this is a big deal I think this is
like I think we're actually part of
something I do also remember the best
thing about it was that those boys I
remember being like I for once I'm in a
room and the two men that see me 100% is
an equal that are writing for me 100% is
an equal if not writing better parts for
me than they were writing for themselves
like it was a really beautiful thing of
like these people coming together that
had the same humor the same intention
and I don't know if that was a beautiful
happy accident I don't know if that was
just something that you know people saw
but it was what it was and I remember
that was the biggest thing for me is
being in the room with those two boys
and going like oh my god this is gonna
be something because we love each other
because we're so excited and because we
get each other on a humor level that is
very rare to be honest like it's we're
stepping it you are stepping into an
established system yeah hierarchy where
there's already this is kind of like
think we're gonna do this and then it
changed a lot from I think the original
what people wanted it to be it was just
supposed to be their very opinionated
this and instead you had these two
people that did love the humor side of
it and did love all that and so I think
it changed a lot with intention with the
intention and it became what it was but
I remember that was that was the biggest
thing that I remember going oh this is
gonna be something because we all really
like each other and we all get along and
this is so much fun you know so that was
a really big awakening for me when you
first remember knowing that you'd become
internet famous when we were doing the
maximum thing that was the creepiest and
the craziest and most wonderful thing
ever
yeah tell us about that it was just I I
think our producer said it as a joke and
then the boys are what I said there's a
maximum Hot 100 List where you write in
people what if we
because someone put it in the comments
like a whole bunch of people were like
we should Willie in there blah blah blah
blah blah and I think it was a big thing
for the producer to be like I wonder if
we could actually do this I wonder if we
could actually you know like it was more
of just a second producer thinking just
being like what does our army entail
right now and so and then I was like
guys I gonna happen and the boys check
it on immediately and they're like oh no
and so they made a video and I remember
they were like oh we crashed the site no
like oh in what world is this a thing
they Joe and Eliot right doing Eliot
we're like they kind of jumped on board
with it they were like oh yeah like
let's just see it was it was I think a
big part of it was like let's see if we
could do this like it wasn't at for me
it was like you know and so they send
people to the site to vote rumor has it
that Maxim then installed a CAPTCHA yes
for you and they had crashed the site
multiple times I mean that is the power
of the Internet well and and now the net
result is well you were on the hot 100
and and you have a you have a Maxum
profile people can which is not
something I never thought I would ever
be able to say I had the most close on
to if anyone ever okay so it you find it
funny how do you feel about it I mean
it's one of those baffling things to me
like I don't get it I'm like sure okay
like if you meet me you might think
differently cuz I fart on the Reg so do
the rest of the girls on the way sure
sound like flowers and whispers coming
out but but you know I mean it's kind of
one of those baffling things like I
don't get it but I'll go along with it
sure and in a weird way it's kind of
nice to be like I feel like I might want
to be one of the only normal people that
actually eats you know normal stuff and
you know actually I don't know I might
be one of the normal people and then
that's kind of nice for me for me I'm
like oh I'm normal and I my boobs are
barely showing there's a cleavage line
and that's about it and it could be my
scars no no
but that was what nothing to that they
were like scarves like absolutely not
you cannot photos that it's mine no
scars no proof like ain't happening and
then yeah that was a big thing about I
was like I was gonna be in a leather
jacket I demanded to be covered mainly
because I was like I have a mother and
father so there's there's two there's
there's two sides to what you're saying
right now there's the one side of I love
this position of strength and confidence
and who you are yeah and but I know even
in the most recent video you talked
about it's true of everyone we're all
self-conscious you know you you put it
out there you're talking about your
self-image yeah talking about that
people commenting are you pregnant
and how you want to lose weight you know
you've got so that's the other side of
it is there is a there's a
self-consciousness too I guess
yes of course I mean I think there is
with everyone I mean it is it's there's
harsher things on women but there's
harsher things on men - in a different
world in a different world of providing
and and where are you 6-8 success for
men is a woman's body like women's
sexual images how men you know in their
success like that's that's the
equivalent in my mind so it's a weird
thing like I mean there are still
self-conscious things I've grown up with
it like it's been I've been a chubby kid
since since puberty which I think did
for him a lot of who I am and did for
him a lot of just like I'm gonna make
you my friend not through you wanting
anything from me but through me making
you laugh you know and I think that was
a big part of it I think
self-consciousness is just one of those
things that is human nature I said in
the vlog recently that like really the
only thing I've struggled with more than
my weight is the idea that it defines me
is the idea that it defines my
self-worth because it is such a weird
thing that like even going on and
auditioning for roles like they'll be
like oh we want like a heavier girl and
you're like great
so you get there and then they're like
no like no like a heavier girl you're
like okay then they go we want a normal
girl you go to something and they go no
like a normal girl so no matter what
you're putting these different brackets
of like it shouldn't matter it shouldn't
matter but it does and that's the
unfortunate world that we live in is
that you know for me it was the
weight-loss thing was like I don't want
to be any part of what holds me back in
this world you know I mean like I I
don't want to hold myself back I don't
want to be the person that has enough
talent and enough Drive to go places but
because the world sees me in a certain
light or doesn't see me as normal or
sees me it's a thicker girl or sees me
as this like I know that I'm not ever
going to be the leading lady but I'll
always be the quirky friend when it
comes to a NBC sitcom I'm ok with that
because that's a way more fun role but
it's just that thing of you know the
self-conscious factor always plays and I
think it does with everyone so for me it
was more of a thing of I would rather
not get those comments of are you
pregnant again
I'm not happen some day but it's just
you know those things of for me it was
more along lines of not getting rid of
those comments but feeling better about
myself in the sense of you know taking
control because controls a big part of
it you know for the last year and a half
I was doing sketch comedy which lends
itself to a lot of horrible food
midnight and 3:00 a.m. decisions and
right it lends itself to you sitting in
front of a computer all day every day
you rarely hike onion but they you know
being in the Maxim Hot 100 is kind of a
victory and turning that on its ear and
saying I'm gonna do it on my terms and
yeah you're not gonna change who I am
and and at the same time is a victory
for the internet because we get to
decide who we say it's hot yes not some
mag airbrushed magazine exactly and I
think that is a big part of it you know
I don't know I think that is one of
those things of I feel like I mean it's
people like Meghan tonjes who I love so
much because she has that like body
revolution the bootie revolution where
she's just like I'm taking we're
changing the idea of what defines a
person that's a big deal so the maximum
thing is a touch point it's a touch by
touch point for your fame another one
another one
we got the inside scoop because Kevin
our producer is friends with your
boyfriend uh-huh yeah yeah yeah and so
we hear there's a target story being
recognized yeah yeah there is it was
like actually probably one of the most
mildly
it's pretty embarrassing actually I
really get embarrassed but this is one
of those where we got embarrassing story
I uh um well I was in a target with my
boyfriend and I I think I'm a lot to
handle but uh he wanted to go to the
home section I did not so I proceeded to
throw a fit where in which I laid down
on the ground and just decided to not go
on you're on my back like I was like I'm
not going I'm not doing it I can't move
like if you want to go to home section
you drag me come the classic toddler
which I tend to do a lot actually it's I
find it hilarious but and also get you
get your way guys as a there were two
year old woman that won't move in laying
down it but you were doing it for
Communities doing okay he was laughing
it wasn't like a thing like I was doing
it for comedic effect okay I can't I
don't I don't possibly have a target
home good section like rant I don't have
in writing in me left all that being
said I'm still getting very nervous at
least like no no and some target
employee came up to me and I thought
like he's gonna like man get off the
floor
and instead he was like are you Lee
Newton I was like and it was probably
the most biggest victory for my
boyfriend because it was just like see
you can't do gotta watch yourself
so that was a big defining moment of I
was like oh I think I might not be able
to do weird things in public anymore I
think and if I do at least it will be
part of my brain right well and now now
that The Groundlings thing is gonna come
yes you know to an end which I can only
imagine how crazy your schedule was it
was about it was like fifty hour
workweek sketch comedy plus on top of it
yeah so I mean what does it look like
now and what are you doing with that
extra time and I know one of them is
focusing more on your personal check
yeah one of them is focusing more on my
personal Channel another one I just got
done with this CBS diversity showcase
which I am Native American no one would
ever be able to tell because
I have a fantastic colorist and because
my father's vicious Irish side took over
but that was a big thing I did and you
know I mean now it's it's going into the
personal channel now it's a weird thing
of pilot season there's a weird part of
me that like I love the Internet I love
that I still love acting I love acting
and doing all that stuff too so it's
that weird I have agents and managers
that I'll pitch you to crazy weird
things and so you know right now when
you say it's pilot season is it the
casting phase like you're you're
auditioning auditioning for pilots
everywhere and you know doing all this
crazy you know weird stuff and I mean
we're like I mean example examples are
like I mean you just it's making an ass
of yourself for comedy again but it's in
an audition in an audition where you
have to like take it so you know like
there's every sitcom there's you know
hyperboles of people it's just like
they're just like okay now this girl's a
valley girl but she's so Chih valley
girl so you have to go in and you dress
the part and you go in and just like oh
my god no wait what's happening how is
this happening and you're like this is a
ridiculous thing that ABC will never
pick up but you gotta go you have to go
for it you have to be those people that
go for all those different things of
like oh and then with this one they want
like a room and I just mean you have to
go for the part I meant you have to go
for it you have to go all the world the
way you're performing yes because
there's you know again there's different
key masters that are in charge of that
world you know there's an patent also
had a really great thing and he talked
about in a just for last commencement
speech that was really wonderful but it
was he was talking about how the
Internet is redefining the keymaster
the Internet has you know and he was he
held up his iPhone he's like there's
more power in this than when Orson
Welles you know made Citizen Kane and
you're like crap that's totally true so
it's unless the battery's dead
exactly it's kind of nice to have both
facets though to like sit there and I
mean I see things like I loved being a
part of my music I walked on set of my
music and I had all these this crew in
this set and I was like holy crap this
is legit like this is a legit thing
I'm looking at a legit schedule I'm
learning how to be in this world through
an internet thing which is fascinating
to me and it's kind of really exciting
too so there's multiple different things
I'm trying out this world and it seems
like the pattern of SourceFed is people
are on SourceFed and then they do it for
a while and they move on to something
else something else so what's the story
with you as that I'm the last of five of
the first three which is a weird feeling
to feel because you're always like you
know I mean I miss my boys completely
but I do know that there's like
tremendous new talent coming in and
that's really exciting to see I would
like to think of it like that is an SNL
type place where you know Phil Hartman
comes back and does something Mike
Meyers come back comes back and hosts
for me it's one of those I don't know
when I will be leaving SourceFed I know
that it's not long for me I know that
it's not it's not my end goal and I
think anyone that knows me knows that
it's not my end goal do I always like
hold a place where do I always plan on
still having my face on that channel as
long as I possibly can and popping in
doing that absolutely because I still
believe in it and I still think it's
like such a wonderful place for stuff
and so I don't I have no idea where I
stand in the sense of like actually that
taking over and right now I'm even down
to like I'm not there as much as I used
to be you know because other stuff in my
life has taken over but I do still think
it's such a wonderful place and I'll
always be that person that like pops in
and does a comment commenting on Weekend
Update you know like so it's just
there's things like that but I don't
know how much longer I am gonna be there
I know that it is going in really great
directions I think that it has different
things for a lot of different people and
and I I hope to be there in some respect
kind of always well let me ask you an
easier planning question since you bring
it up I mean so I mean when are you
gonna have a baby
oh god it's really let's look it's like
a subliminal think about it guys um I
don't know I have no idea I have a niece
she's killer she's like really doing
great on the knees front and after about
four hour
I go whoa these are a lot of work I
don't know you're the one you've
mentioned it number a number of times I
was just wanted to make sure I know well
it's one of those things that you just
have to let everyone know I'm not going
to it's a weird thing as a woman there's
so much things that it's like I wish if
if someone else could have it oh man I'd
have four but four or five at least I
think I want a dog first and then I
start with a dog okay but I do love dogs
I really do love dogs but that would be
if must love dogs wasn't already a
romantic comedy that would be my
romantic comedy dog but I do love
animals and so I feel like that's a good
start right is animals before babies
Korea before animals all that so what's
the name of the dog you don't have or
the kid that you don't have the name of
innocent one that I don't have will be
timer timer timer cool name don't steal
it anyone I'm just letting you know
without like I would a T IME
okay and when did you choose who I am
here I heard it once and I was like dude
that's the [ __ ] me what what grade were
you in
it wasn't someone's name it was a swim
they said timers a lot of timers that's
basically a guy's name timer I like I
like really interesting names
I like names that are occupations so
that's a great one it's either cobbler
so you know cobbler is the dog's name
sniper beef beef or it's knife depending
I need to see the dog but snarfer are
snart's Newton out but snarf is a real
one that I've a new smell constantly
about wanting a snare I knew that you
had thought about these names I know of
course talk about I had a vivid dream
three nights ago that I adopted this dog
named buster
and I remember like texting my boyfriend
and being like Oh God like I'm
broken I woke up I did not realize this
cannot be it he doesn't want a dog now
of course he wants one but it I think
he's probably tired of me going like
good we're gonna get a dog figure it out
like let's get a dog already dream dogs
mean dogs that's right Matt get a career
get a dog
we'll get that pin I'd love to design
the price table finest space this is a
lot of fun it's great to hang out thank
you guys got a lot of podium talk good
we need to mean who knows also removing
to remind everyone that I mainly based
my humor in farts so you know I mean it
can't all be you know that's like really
how much validity does she have a second
that instinct you know oh nice I put it
over there there's an EXO and there's
three exclamation points really excited
thanks Lee thank you
[Music]
there it is our ear biscuit with Lee
Newton super appreciative to leave for
coming in and being at the round table
of dim light let her know what you think
by tweeting at her her handle is Lee
Newton says Lee Newton says so check ear
biscuit for that hashtag and let her
know what she thought of this I gotta
say that I when I was listening to Lee
talked about this Jam that she's been
making hmm I try not to be too
overzealous but I was expressing a
distinct interest in it oh yeah I picked
up on that you were you really perked up
in and she started writing about Jam
well I want to be on the list I want to
be on the list Lee that's the deal I
want to be on the list when she makes
that Jam I want her to have a red jar
well I mean she basically said that I'm
in if I give her some of my dad's
barbecue sauce so I mean you could we
could work out a distribution but y'all
from her to me to you it but you also
said that your dad can't ship the
barbecue sauce he brings it out like
from a trailer Christmastime but she
also said that he can ship it out and
that he's holding out on me
and so I have
to have a conversation with my dad it's
like what yeah what dad is it not
shippable okay so this is how it works
you ship the barbecue sauce no your dad
ships the barbecue sauce to you you hand
deliver the barbecue sauce to Lee it's a
big jug you get two jars of jam you
bring about you give me one that's sound
like a deal I'm missing a one-component
what do you give me money I gave you the
idea the I expressed interest you gave
me the distribution yeah yeah yeah I'm
the facilitator I'm the facilitator
facilitator gets a cut cut a jam like
boysenberry y'all you're boysenberry
I like all jams jellies yeah that's for
the birds
what's Jam what's the real difference do
you know I know it when I see it I've
always thought that the Jam had more
fruit in it and the jelly was just like
a gelatin yeah something what's it
preserves preserves our Jam to me no I
think preserves you can put things in
them like you can interchange things in
them like a dead animal you can put you
could preserve like a little chicken in
a and jam in preserves I'm sure that the
music came in a long time ago right I
know that they're gonna keep talking
about the difference these jellies jams
it preserves but but you ear biscuit ear
are on your way out and yeah but we're
gonna keep talking about it but you
should I
I'll preserve anything especially if
it's Jam okay well you said that your
biscuit ears were all no way out and
that's fine as long as they find their
way back in next week because we will be
here I was gonna say same time same
place
but I mean we will but you can enjoy
this whenever you want to any time any
place will be here shove us in your ears
no shove this in your ears I like that
new slogan okay see you next week
[Music]
[Music]